it turns out when there's a small lesion
in one part of the brain what you get is
not an across-the-board reduction of all
your mental capacity sort of blunting of
your mental functions what you see is a
highly selective loss of one specific
function such as recognizing faces or
reading other functions being preserved
intact so you can this gives you some
confidence in saying that that region is
somehow specialized for that function
you can then home in on the
microcircuitry in that region see what
it's connected to and understand the
functional logic how and map function on
the structure so that's the goal of the
whole enterprise so what we do is look
at patients who've sustained injury look
at how their behavior how their mind has
changed and ask ourselves what can this
tell you about the functions of the
normal brain that's one agenda and then
there's a clinical agenda of crime to
help the patient and sometimes we
succeed sometimes we don't one example
of this is compound illusion if the
person says this woman looks just like
my mother doctor but she's an imposter
she's some other woman pretending to be
my mother so there's a strong emotional
component to it sometimes requires a
little paranoid flavor why is this woman
following all the time she's not my
mother she looks like my mother but
she's not mostly pretending to be my
mother okay so what causes this what we
think is going on here is the pathway
visual pathways are normal fusiform
gyrus is normal that's why he can
recognize a mother today it looks like
my mother but the wire that goes from
there to the amygdala is cut by the
accident therefore he looks at his
mother and there is no emotional arousal
so there's no warmth when he looks at
his mother or no fear when he looks at
his mother it seems bizarre to you and
me but given the disconnection in his
brain between vision and emotion vision
is normal emotion is normal but the two
are uncoupled only if sensible
interpretation is this very bizarre
interpretation that she's an impostor
but if you come up with an anatomical
explanation you solve the mystery you do
Sherlock Holmes like deduction here and
then you analyze what's going on and
it's mystery solved and you can test it
experimentally using a very simple
procedure
another even more bizarre disorder if
you can believe it is crota's disorder
where a person says I am NOT alive I'm
dead I'm a rotting dead body
I've been buried my corpse I can smell
my stinking corpse now why does quat
erika we don't know but is a
representation of self dislike the
representation of other people in your
brain and when there's an alienation of
the self because of some kind of
disconnection going on in the brain that
main contribute to cotton syndrome but
also just as in Carrboro syndrome the
disconnection between visual sensory
signals in the amygdala and limbic
structures so that your mother fails to
evoke emotion imagine a much more
widespread disconnection of all sensory
input hearing touch vision everything is
disconnected from the limbic structures
there's an impoverished sense of self
and alienation of self none of the
sensations in the external world have
any emotion significance that's about as
close as you can get to existing shelana
halation